.
BILL HEMMER HAVE A GREAT
WEEKEND.
JOINING US, FORMER SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
NEWT GINGRICH.
YOU'VE BEEN STEADFAST IN TERMS
OF PREDICTING THAT THIS
ENVIRONMENT THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
NOW RUNNING IN, THE FACT THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOTHING POSITIVE
TO RUN ON, THAT THEY'RE NOW BACK
TO THE OLD SCARE SENIORS,
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO TAKE
AWAY YOUR SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE.
TO ME THAT'S A SIGN OF
DESPERATION.
LET'S WALK THROUGH WHAT YOU SEE,
WHAT YOU PREDICT, WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN ON TUESDAY NIGHT.
>> WELL, I THINK AT A GENERAL
LEVEL WE'LL BE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
PLUS THREE AND PLUS FIVE IN THE
SENATE.
THE ONE WHICH I THINK IS HANGING
IN THE BALANCE IS A TERRIFIC
CANDIDATE, TIFFANY SMILEY IN
WASHINGTON STATE.
WASHINGTON STATE IS A VERY TOUGH
STATE FOR US.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO WIN ALL
THE REPUBLICAN SEATS, WHICH WILL
INCLUDE OZ IN PENNSYLVANIA, J.D.
VANCE, AND INCLUDE PEOPLE LIKE
MARCO RUBIO HANDILY, AND WE'LL
KEEP THE SEAT IN NORTH CAROLINA
AND IN WISCONSIN WITH RON
JOHNSON.
THEN I THINK WE'RE GOING TO PICK
UP NEW HAMPSHIRE, AS PEOPLE GO
UP AND FILL UP THEIR OIL HEATING
TANKS FOR THE WINTER, THE PRICE
SHOCK IS ENORMOUS.
HASSAN IS A WEAK SENATOR.
I THINK WE'LL PICK UP THE SEAT
IN NEVADA.
>> Sean: AND GEORGIA?
>> LOOK, I'M AN OPTIMIST.
I THINK HERSCHEL WALKER WILL WIN
WITHOUT A RUNOFF.
I THINK THAT BRIAN KEMP THAT IS
DONE SUCH A GREAT JOB, PUT
TOGETHER SUCH A POWERFUL TEAM
THAT HE'S GOING TO BEAT STACY BY
A BIG MARGIN.
IN THAT PROCESS, HE'LL CARRY
HERSCHEL ABOVE 50%.
AND FRANKLY BLAKE MASTERS WILL
WIN IN ARIZONA, WHERE YOU HAVE
IN KELLY SOMEBODY WHO PRETENDS
TO BE A MODERATE, BUT IN FACT
HAS CONSISTENTLY FAVORED MORE
IRS AGENTS OVER MORE BORDER
PATROL, AND PEOPLE OF ARIZONA
KNOW IT.
SO I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A
GREAT NIGHT.
ON THE HOUSE SIDE, SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN PLUS 20 AND PLUS 50.
I PERSONALLY THINK IT WILL BE
ABOUT 44.
AND KEVIN McCARTHY IS THE NEXT
SPEAKER.
>> Sean: WOW.
THAT'S A TOLD PREDICTION.
WHEN YOU THINK OF ALL THESE
RACES, A LOT OF THEM ARE EITHER
DEAD EVEN IN THE POLLS, OR A
ONE-POINT ADVANTAGE, OR
TWO-POINT ADVANTAGE.
I'M TALKING ABOUT MORE
SPECIFICALLY, I'LL BREAK IT
DOWN, GEORGIA, NEW HAMPSHIRE,
PENNSYLVANIA, NEVADA, AND
ARIZONA IN PARTICULAR.
THOSE RACES SEEMED TO BE THE
TOUGHEST RIGHT NOW.
I'D ADD TIFFANY SMILEY IN
WASHINGTON STATE.
WHEN YOU SEE RACES THAT ARE THAT
TIGHT, HOW SHOULD PEOPLE
INTERPRET THAT?
BECAUSE NOW YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, BETWEEN ALL
THOSE RACES I JUST MENTIONED,
YOU KNOW, MAYBE 30,000, 40,000,
50,000 VOTES WILL DETERMINE THE
WINNER IN ALL THOSE RACES
COMBINED.
>> WELL, IT COULD BE.
WE WON WITH REAGAN, WITH WON
CONTROL OF THE SENATE WHEN
NOBODY EXPECTED IT, AND THE
TOTAL MARGIN WAS AMAZINGLY
SMALL, BUT KEPT WINNING SEATS BY
15,000, 20,000.
TWO THINGS TO REMEMBER HERE.
ONE IS WITH ALL THE VICIOUS
HATEFUL LANGUAGE FROM BIDEN AND
OTHERS, YOU SUPPRESS THE
REPUBLICAN WILLINGNESS TO TALK
TO POLLSTERS.
IT'S MUCH HARDER TO GET AN
ACCURATE READ ON REPUBLICANS
RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE THEY FRANKLY
DON'T WANT TO TELL PEOPLE WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO.
PEOPLE WILL FILL UP THEIR GAS
TANK, GO TO THE GROCERY STORE,
WATCH THE EVENING NEWS, THE
NORMAL WEEKEND CARNAGE IN
CHICAGO, THE MURDERS IN NEW
YORK.
I THINK BY THE TIME IT'S OVER,
ALMOST NOBODY WHO'S CURRENTLY
UNDECIDED IS GOING TO DECIDE TO
VOTE DEMOCRAT.
SO YOU CAN TAKE -- IF THE
DEMOCRATS BELOW 51% OR 52%, I
PERSONAL BELIEVE THEY'RE
PROBABLY GONE.
SO YOU SHOW ME A 46%, 47% RACE,
THE DEMOCRAT IS AHEAD BY ONE.
NO, THAT DEMOCRAT AT 47,
PROBABLY BEHIND 53-47, BECAUSE I
THINK ALL THE FINAL VOTES ARE
GOING TO GO AGAINST THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, I'VE LEARNED
OVER THE MANY YEARS, BEING THE
EMCEE THE NIGHT YOU BECAME
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, A NIGHT
I'LL NEVER FORGET, AND WAS
HONORED TO BE A PART OF.
YOU'VE NEVER BEEN WRONG.
YOU ARE ALMOST ALWAYS RIGHT.
>> ALMOST ALWAYS.
>> Sean: AM ALWAYS.
VERY C